welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and now that we know kang the
conqueror is the big bad the mcu is
working up to in quantum media and kang
dynasty and secret wars we are now left
re-examining the sacred timeline of his
to figure out exactly what he did to
make it so sacred whenever we learn
about one villain being the author of
all a pain every voice we have ever
heard inside our heads one who's gone by
many names a ruler a conqueror a jerk
it's easy to go nuts and retroactively
attribute every butterfly fart to one
mastermind and since he who remains
scripted every um and uh to come from
loki and silvi's mouths hey maybe marvel
studios plans to do just that for kang
but when you look at phase 4 alone you
can actually connect the dots among
specific actions that kang took actually
10 changes that he made to the timeline
his fingerprints recorded throughout
history and unlike the stuff we
theorized about this actually looks like
intentional evidence by the studio so
let us break down these 10 pieces of
evidence the 10 things that we know for
sure kang did so the kang variant he
remains claimed i
paved
the road you
he just walked down there now we still
don't know how truthful he remains was
being there whether he was taking credit
solely for things he did or for things
kings have done collectively it's an
important distinction but based on the
accuracy of his script alone i think we
can say this kang variant drafted the
sacred timeline aka universe 616. but
does that sacred timeline script include
just the events that we saw in the loki
series or does it also include events
that are on the sacred timeline aka the
616 universe as that film reel in
episode 1 was labeled 616. or since the
loki who watched that footage departed
from that timeline from 2012 and the
footage showed his future through the
dark world ragnarok and infinity war i
think we have to credit he remains with
drafting that history too the history of
the 616 mcu that we've been following
but to carry out his vision of the
sacred timeline this kang variant
created the tva and the void and all of
the temporal tech everything the tva did
to prune that sacred timeline this kang
was responsible for that includes the
detaining of the variants like loki and
sylvie the kidnapping and the
brainwashing of the tva employees like
mobius b15 and rinslayer and all the
variants and objects that were pruned
into the void and the structure of the
void itself in the leashing and
harnessing of goliath but this brings up
a few more implications of kang's
possible plan because you could also say
he led loki and silvi to kill him and to
open the multiverse up in order to
unleash his variants this way
till you meet all right
see you soon
but the question there is was silvi
killing him just an inevitable thing
that would happen and he arranged it
specifically as a kind of dead man
switch a fail-safe measure against his
rival variants or he was just tired and
he wanted the game to end or he knew
that there was only so much he could do
against his fellow variants it needed
the avengers and heroes like sylvian
loki to do what he couldn't now he
remains also likely had a history with
ravana rinslayer that will probably
learn more about moki's season two
ranslayer's hunter designation was a23 a
nod to avengers 23 in 1965 which was the
first comic appearance of ravana
rinslayer when kang tried to
romantically woo ravonna but we don't
know where rent slayer goes at the end
of season one or what her true
motivations are but there is a good
chance she and this kang variant had
some thing in the past she might stay
working in the tva out of fear of him
remember there was that mysterious
broken fourth timekeeper statue and he
remained citadel its broken pieces just
left broken on the floor maybe this
someone who was dumped just leaves a
broken picture frame on the floor and
when asked about this the production
designer of loki told vanity fair i
can't say anything about it
unfortunately but the answers will be
forthcoming i have always wondered if
ren slayer was this kang's first time
keeper the leader of those four but when
she didn't reciprocate his love he
demoted her to judge status and turn the
other three into automatons now of
course there are these 616 avengers that
this kang was involved with we know this
kang spared the 616 avengers we know he
who remains made an exception for the
avengers subversion of the sacred
timeline and avengers endgame that he
did not extend to loki you have the
wrong person oh really and who should we
have i suspect the avengers we're not
here to talk about the avengers oh no no
what they did was supposed to happen you
escaping was not i went into his
possible motivations in another video
but again it might be because he needed
the avengers to defeat his rival kang
dynasty because he himself could not do
it and by allowing them to discover time
travel he left them with the keys to do
so now you guys have seen my videos
enough to know that i watch a lot of tv
a lot of movies and i re-watch
everything a bazillion times just in
case i missed something but depending on
where you live there's a lot of stuff
that you just can't watch unless you're
using a vpn and if you're using a vpn
you really should be using expressvpn so
expressvpn makes it so that your digital
location doesn't have to match your
physical location it protects your data
from hackers and keeps anybody from
logging what you're doing online and
most importantly it unlocks all kinds of
content that you might be missing out on
simply because of where you happen to be
logging in from like if you want to
watch spirited away on netflix normally
if you were in the us you're out of luck
but with expressvpn all you've got to do
is just switch your location to the uk
you refresh a page and you're good to go
if you're in the uk switch your location
all of a sudden you can be watching
vikings expressvpn is so easy to use all
you got to do is open the app and
connect with just one click it's a
top-rated vpn provider rated number one
by techradar find out how you can get
three months of expressvpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com new rockstars or
by clicking the link in the description
below so as we look ahead to quantomania
we also know another kang kills
countless avengers the comic-con footage
for quantomania ends with kang asking
scott lang you're an avenger have i
killed you before that means this kang
has killed so many avengers he doesn't
remember which of them he's killed
quantomania of course will also probably
show how involved this kang was in the
quantum realm and its time vortexes but
i also think that he who remains might
have been involved with every new marvel
hero we are meeting in phase four i
asked iman valani about kamala khan
going back in time and iman laughed
about how she too initially wondered
whether it broke marvel's logic but then
teased that the marvels will further
explain how the bangle enabled her to
time travel and then i asked her another
question and her answer was probably the
most interesting thing to come out of
this interview do you think kang or he
remains might have planned specifically
for kamala to go back in time
yeah okay so the inscription on the
bengal used to be what is destined for
you will come for you we did change it
after that but i like to use that as a
way of
you know justifying how kamala goes back
in time and why that was meant to happen
and this is a huge deal yes iman vilani
only has a few pieces of the overall
puzzle but it sounds like if a kang
variant allowed the avengers to go back
in time to save themselves he also
allowed kamala khan to go back in time
why what we'll probably find out in the
marvels but i'm guessing it was to
position ms marvel in battle world in
secret wars to create the circumstances
of this girl even existing so that she
could one day be a superhero maybe to
give his variant iron lad a teammate on
the young avengers and whether or not ms
marvel joins the young avengers this
does bring up another piece of kang
evidence that we haven't talked much
about ever since hawkeye because
remember that watch from avengers
compound that we later learned belonged
to laura barton mockingbird was numbered
268 and at the time many of us
speculated that this could be a kang
clue and were mocked for it but when you
go back and look at that avengers 268
was the beginning of a storyline called
wait for it the kang dynasty yes hawkeye
was signaling where this is all headed
so if we consider this item kang
connected it's possible that one of the
kangs displaced this watch into the
hands of black market dealers so that
kate bishop would have this chance
encounter with clint parton and become
the next hawkeye leader of the young
avengers this would also support the
theory that he remains was a rogue
sympathetic king who helped his avengers
survive and in this case alter the
timeline so that the young avengers
would form and include his iron lad
variant now there was a clearer kang
sighting than moon knight in episode
three one of the egyptians mark spector
chases down has a jacket with the
imprint of pharaoh rama tut one of the
known identities of kang the conqueror
this was confirmed to us by a producer
on that series he remains even alluded
to this past i've been dubbed many names
by many people a ruler a conqueror a
jerk this tells us that within the 616
history ancient history was an egyptian
ruler named pharaoh rama tut and kang
therefore meddled with egyptian gods and
moon knight and there was a second kang
clue in that final sequence of this
season of moon night when jake lockley
wheels arthur harrow passed a poster
with a qr code that when you scanned it
took you to a 2019 moon night acts of
evil comic when moon knight and kang
race through time and alternate
timelines in search of three totems of
konju this could be a subplot of
avengers kang dynasty a task moon knight
does to defeat one of the kangs of the
council so coming back around to that
dastardly kang we're about to meet in
quantomania we know he remains as a
history of violence he admitted he
killed other nathaniel richards variants
to win that past multiversal war and
build the tva in the void that tells us
that the way the avengers might be able
to defeat the kang dynasty will be to
turn the kangs against each other and
since he remains spared the 616 avengers
and allowed them to keep tony stark's
quantum navigation tech the ability to
travel through time one could argue that
this one kang left the avengers with the
tools they need to bring down the
dynasty follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow me rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you